people of the internet retro reckons who  are here avalanche has released another  tiny little teaser for this coming  thursday stay to play event when they  are going to fully unveil 14 minutes of  gameplay footage for hogwarts legacy all  i know is that from seeing this very  brief clip i was just hit with a wave of  nostalgia the moment i saw the shot of  that character waking up in the  gryffindor dormitory immediately takes  me back to the old school games waking  up in the dormitory for the first time  the happy hogwarts music kicks in you've  got the nice little moving portrait in  the background oh just so much nostalgia  thursday is gonna be epic you guys i  will be streaming this live over on  twitch.tv slash retrorecontour can't  wait to experience this all with you  guys